hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the static speaks my name
now I've been very much recommended to
play this game but I've been told that
it is very very serious game that needs
to be taken seriously because it covers
very heavy subjects not that I know what
they are but just I wanted to warn you
in the beginning because if you're
sensitive to certain things like I think
this might be involving just be aware
it's going to get very serious why am i
floating among stars and what the hell
is that thing big amorphous blob
oh I'm walking towards it okay nevermind
okay why am i walking towards the thing
are you the static that speaks my name
name Jacob urn Holtz age 31 method in
asphyxiation by hanging well I guess
that gives an idea of what this game is
gonna be about he didn't rekt oh the
static speaks my name so I think that
gives a good include today whoa hey
today will be a better day that is a
very very very creepy painting to pair
with hearts why am I getting up at 3:22
a.m. why is that the world's quietest
alarm
objective one used the bathroom okay why
is that an objective why is that
something that needs to be done my
babies printed bite are those my babies
are they shrimp they look fantastic I
guess I would never want anything to
happen to my babies open door well I
guess I need to complete my objective
hooray I did it congratulations me I'm
doing so good I mean obviously like the
game told me exactly what's gonna happen
in the end of the game
all you didn't flush you didn't flush
how gross eat breakfast okay
well ain't this just a peach no not yet
all right cool all right
okay whoa what the hell why is this all
boarded up take keys what do I need keys
I can't even get out why are there TVs
with static and is that the static
speaking my name and how did I know like
before I went into the level or
something whatever that was the level
select how did I know oh oh okay oh okay
what's my unhealthy obsession with this
painting or picture painting I'm
assuming it's a painting
to do four hidden door to safe room have
lock on the door fitted so I can use my
house key glue down lighten up upright
books and make books look casual hon
shelf so people aren't suspicious I
don't think anyone's gonna get inside
through all of your boarded up doors h2
this is too formal it's a good amount of
casual this is so casual it looks fake
right okay this is is he trying to find
the Illuminati in the trees why huh I
don't understand what in the world
signature too sensitive to infrared do
what huh
what okay
yeah oh seven flavors doing Wow
what in the world is all this okay
anyway I've left palm AKA hand of God
okay I'm out of here because Wow
holy cow oh I needed to eat breakfast I
kind of got distracted by the thing
that's consuming this person's life now
what's interesting about these games is
oh hello
oh no food still empty I guess it's
shrimp again no my babies I can't eat my
babies oh no no no no okay what's
interesting about these types games is
it you know ever since I play like
presentable Liberty it's been pretty
obvious it when I play these games oh I
don't want it I don't wanna oh no my
babies we're gonna cook them but gonna
cook up alive I'm gonna eat them
oh come on
I just ate them straight up cheese oh
man my babies they even say my babies
chat online with friends okay
is this looking too casual there is that
where the hidden bookshelf is oh man
God that is so creepy this is so weird
why is any of this a thing why does this
have to be a thing anyway like I said
when I play these games especially the
serious very very serious games I like
live them more than I do anything oh
oh man
that's the suicide note if you didn't
know science
oh you're horny great great I'm sure
this isn't spam and all rusty to say
you're embarrassed Aaron evening you
come on oh man I just I just saw that
painting down there or that picture that
is that is a rather disturbing picture
is that my friends press H to say you
can feel the atoms in your body what
does it even mean but I guess it's the
other better than the other one I just
okay alright it's it's not gonna matter
what happens because it's always gonna
say the same thing
oh you're touching yourself great
Christie to say you're about to do
something horrible press H to admit you
saw your reflection be decapitated with
a shovel what does that mean ah why am I
saying these things
yeah this sent me a credit card info oh
good I'm glad I'm going to stand up now
great I'm glad I chatted with my friends
who apparently were all offline clean
them clean the microwave why is that an
objective
I guess I'll close the fridge before I
do I want to make sure of my life is
completely in order goodness I need a
paper towel
oh of course because normal human beings
would rate what was in there anyway
assignment just I what to do with the
man in the cage
what does I ever been why do I have a
man in the cage is he behind the hidden
bookshelf he's lying hidden bookshelf is
he always behind a bookshelf grocery
list food lightbulbs forgot three times
- any more pain oh I don't know why any
more pain Electric you the man live the
gauge why would I want to do that all I
cracy goes to our guest in case of
emergency who is our who is we why is
this a thing why am I boarded up in my
own house I can't get groceries without
them pleases I think this is some
apocalyptic scenario why do I have a man
in a cage
Oh oh good it is okay oh great
Oh God need sleep tired tired tired why
is this a thing
now yourself oh hey oh hey hey
ah
oh yes what true
return to your room and let your body
run
I mean I know what it means but man oh
man my body resumes
why did I have a man in a cage
Oh Oh get a chill I noticed as a game
but goddamn why why do I have to live
this I have so many questions
Oh
you
oh hey oh don't tell me I have to do a
goddamn Ken ah okay so there's more of
them now how many do I have to go
through why is this one black nanny
hanford self-evaluation 16 Barbie head
quiz left from condo knock knees CF
Lincoln 73 the mute all overdose Vinson
Amalia throat cut with a carving knife
I'm guessing I'm supposed to go towards
the darker one but that's not a good
thing
oh that's the end oh okay Oh
why did I need to go through that why
did I need to live that I guess I guess
to see from the perspective of someone
who's I don't know suicidal but there's
so many more questions of that why was
the painting such a point of interest
why was there a man in a cage behind a
hidden bookshelf I mean obviously behind
a hidden bookshelf because can't keep
that out in the open I guess I don't
even understand that I don't even
understand why oh and that's it oh okay
it's just gonna exit the game on me oh
man I need to process this you know if
there's a moral to this game I'm not
seeing it and it's not for lack of
trying I really don't understand why
this game was what it is but if it is to
see what it's like to act out someone
who's going to take their own life
that's horrible in and of itself I mean
the game itself is an artistic piece
obviously it's meant to portray
something and elicit emotions as most
art is supposed to do but damn man I
don't know what message it's trying to
say but I'll just add my own if I can
and I just want to say that you know
I've spoken out before about it before
and I've done a charity stream for
depression and bipolar Alliance Society
and I've to say that if you're
contemplating any sort of self-harm or
suicide you know I I can only say that
there's always a better option and it's
a rather broad sweeping thing to say
that and probably not even my place to
say it to you but I'm let's say it
anyway because saying anything but that
and saying that there's alternatives to
not doing it it's just it's not okay
it's irresponsible to say that and you
know I know that people situations can
be terrible and people can be in just
the worst hell that they've ever
experienced in their life and yet still
there is reason to live and I may not
know it I don't know your specific
situation I don't know what you're going
through
but I can tell you that there has to be
a better way so if you or anyone you
know is going through these four
or thinking about suicide in any way
just know that there would be people
that would be crushed to know that you
chose that I mean at the end of the day
it's it's your choice and there's
nothing that anyone could do about it if
you really wanted to do it but you know
just remember that if no one else if a
guy in a camera from the internet from
half a world away can say that he cares
just know that I really mean it you know
I I would hate I mean it's happened
before actually I've gotten message from
people that you know people that were or
relations of people that were fans of
mine and they tell me you know it's
really hard things to take in but just
know that you know if you remember this
community and your this message is
reaching you in any way just know that I
do care and even if I can't care all
that much because I don't know you I
still care so anyway this is like I said
at the beginning of this video this is
very serious subject and very very hard
thing to take sometimes but just know
that there's a big ol community of
people out here that would love to give
you any sort of love and let you know
that you're not alone so anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out presentable Liberty if you really
are so inclined to see me break down
again in a different way and I hope you
have a great day I don't mean to bring
anyone down with this I don't mean to be
so sad in this video but hey that
sometimes just the way it goes because I
don't know sometimes as this way it is
but I hope you guys aren't brought down
by it I hope you guys have a great day I
hope you guys do great things I hope you
have a good life check out some of my
happy or silly videos if you're so
inclined but thank you everybody so much
for watching and thank you for being
here and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
god it's like this
Ava's a crushing sense of loneliness and
it reminds me that I'm sitting in a room
alone doing a let's play of a game
talking to a camera come with me baby
we're gonna go oh oh god one chance is
it too late